[Music]
these mourners in eastern kenya are
preparing to bury their loved one
daniel musica was an electoral official
who was in charge of a contentious
talent center in nairobi
he disappeared two days after darling
began
his body was found in another town
police say he was tortured
his family believes he was targeted for
political reasons for the dead is
because of politics
we have seen so many issues about
political debts
people get lost mysteriously
and you hear that we are doing an
investigation investigation this time
around i don't know
the for the past times
we have seen that justice has not been
found
neighbors here are still in shock the
relatives of musica say they have many
questions for the authorities they want
to know why he was killed and they want
justice
in north eastern kenya another election
official was shot when armed men
attacked his styling center
doctors could not save muhammad ahmed's
leg he blamed police for shooting him an
officer came from nowhere
shot at me
and left me
crying for help
at the national talling center some
people tried to stop the electoral chief
wafula chabukati from declaring
presidential results and let me thank
president-elect william ruto won the
election but that has been disputed by
former prime minister rail odinga who
came second
chebukati says his employees continue to
face threats human rights groups say
they are worried the diabetes just the
way it prepares for other processes of
elections
but from my seed i think it is called a
protection inbuilt protection mechanisms
for its officials because what we
understand right now like now the
returning officers who are under threat
they feel completely isolated
and also exposed
the election may be over for some people
but for muslim and ahmed families they
say their trauma will take a long while
to heal catherine soy al jazeera
machaco's county